[موسيقى]
انظر إلى ذلك هناك ، الطفل الموجود
في الخلف
، إنه مذهل تمامًا ،
إنه أمر بسيط حقًا ، كلما
سافرت إلى المزيد من أنحاء العالم ، أريد أن
أرى
[موسيقى]
نجاح باهر
[موسيقى
] وهذه إحدى الزوايا التي تم
إغلاقها  لفترة طويلة جدًا
ممن كانوا يعلمون بوجود قرود البابون في المملكة العربية السعودية
[موسيقى]
يذهبون إلى حوالي 900 كيلومتر جنوب غرب
الرياض ويصعدون إلى
المنطقة الجبلية بمحافظة عسير إلى أبها المعروفة
باسم المدينة في السماء
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان أبا  المنشق خلال
أوقات المحافظة الشديدة في المملكة العربية السعودية
وعلى مدى قرون قبل أن
يزدهر التعبير الإبداعي هنا في أي عام
سيكون هذا العام 19 مثل 19
19. كنت جالسًا هناك ، نعم
قرية الفنون المفتاحة حيث جاء
الفنان السعودي الشهير عبد الناصر جارم.
مراهق يتدرب عند
أقدام كبار السن ،
هل تتذكر أين كنت ، نعم ،
أين كنت؟
مع قانون ديني صارم
ضد الكثير مما كان يتم إنتاجه
هنا ومع ذلك تم تمويله من قبل الحكومة ،
كان المثال الكلاسيكي للتناقض السعودي
هذا ثوريًا ، أليس كذلك
في ذلك الوقت كان في البلد بأكمله
كان مثل
المكان الوحيد الذي يوجد فيه  يمكنك العثور على الفن
والموسيقى وكان من الصعب جدًا أن نكون صادقين
لأننا نشعر بمقاومة
المجتمع من هذا ، وقد أتى ما
أعتقد أنه شرارة لما
يحدث الآن في جميع أنحاء المملكة ، حيث
نشأ فنانو التغيير هنا لإيجاد صوت
و  إيجاد سبب لاستخدامه
لإنشاء حوار
لسرقة المحادثة يمكننا أن نتهم من
خلال الفن
بأي قضية نريد
إضافتها إلى تعقيد عبد الناصر ،
ذهب ليصبح عقيدًا
في المؤسسة البحتة للجيش السعودي
ولكن التحدي والاستجواب
هل تقود
أنت تتابع ، هل تستفز أو
ترد ، أعتقد كفنان أنني بحاجة إلى
القيادة لأنك بحاجة إلى أن تكون
متقدمًا بخطوتين عما يحدث وأن
تضع الكثير  من النقاط ودع الناس
يربطونها وأنت تعلم أنهم سيكونون
مسؤولين عن البيان الذي سيكون
الناس على استعداد لدفع ثمن تلك
المحادثة التي تبدأ بمئات
الآلاف من الدولارات في المزاد ،
هناك حاشية لقصة عبد الناصر
أثرت على فنه
الذي ذهب إليه.  إلى المدرسة مع اثنين من الخاطفين 911 ،
لن تصدقني أنهم كانوا مثل
أحد أعز أصدقائي ، لقد كانوا نقيين جدًا لدرجة
أنهم كانوا صادقين جدًا ، ما كان أول ما
فكرت به عندما قال أحدهم بالمناسبة
لقد تم اختطاف ما كان
فكرتك الأولى
لماذا لم أكن أنا
[موسيقى] ،
تعلم أننا كنا في نفس
البيئة نفس التعليم منذ ذلك الوقت
بدأت أدرك أن هذه
مسؤوليتي تجاه
التأكد حقًا
مما
سأستوعبه ولدي الحق  أن أقول لا أو نعم ،
إنها قصة رائعة حقًا ، أليس كذلك
أعتقد أن هذا ما يساعدني في أن أصبح
فنانًا ،
كيف تغير هذا البلد ، أعتقد
أننا نعيش في قصة كبرى
ويمكنني أن أسميها تنوير
وأعتقد أننا ما زلنا في مرحلة
بناء الخطاب خطابنا
[موسيقى]
هذه المدينة في السماء
هي واحة فوق الغيوم
مذهلة فقط
أنا هنا كما وجدت في كل مكان ، مرحبًا ،
مرحباً
، ترحيباً حاراً ،
إنه لأمر رائع أن
أجلس فقط  بهدوء يكاد يكون تأمليًا
كما يقول المثل ، فقط عندما
تغرب الشمس
يرى المرء
كيف سار اليوم